[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend
nikon rauscht weiter durchs land morgen
wird sich wieder eine mpk damit befassen
nach allem was man bisher hört sind
keine neuen massnahmen geplant aber
vorerst soll es auch noch keine
lockerungen geben dem robert koch
institut wurden
85.000 440 neuinfektionen gemeldet
außerdem kam innerhalb eines tages 54
todesfälle dazu allerdings wissen wir ja
dass die sonntags zahlen wegen des melde
verzugs am wochenende in der regel zu
niedrig angegeben sind die sieben tage
incidents hat zum ersten mal den wert
von 800 überschritten und zeigt damit
steil nach oben
der expertenrat der bundesregierung
warnt vor belastungen der krankenhäuser
das betrifft auch die normalstation auf
die patienten eigentlich aus anderen
gründen eingeliefert werden patricia
schäfer berichtet
routinefall in einer notaufnahme in
regensburg ein patient mit verdacht auf
eine corona infektion wird eingeliefert
sofort getestet und es bestätigt sich es
ist omikron die neue welle ist im
anrollen das heißt auch viele
mitarbeiter werden sich krank melden
darauf bereitet sich auch das
uniklinikum regensburg vor wir haben
studenten zum beispiel zusätzlich
akquirieren können wir haben menschen
die mitarbeiter den teilzeit gearbeitet
haben wären sozusagen die haben ihr
pensum
erhöht wir haben themen zusammengestellt
die fest in den schichten gearbeitet
habe ich darf alle wieder sehr herzlich
begrüßen dr zimmermann leitet nicht nur
die notaufnahme sondern koordiniert auch
die abstimmung mit den anderen kliniken
und niedergelassenen ärzten der region
wir sehen nach wie vor steigende
instanzen das spiegelt sich nicht in der
krankenhaus belegung die wöchentliche
video konferenz der ärzte und kliniken
ein wichtiges mittel um patientenströme
zu leiten falls ein krankenhaus vor
läuft wissen alle sofort wo noch platz
ist zum ersten mal wird berichtet auch
auf den normalen stationen kommt die
neue welle an
seit fünf tagen sind alle positiv
getesteten in regensburg mit der omicron
variante infiziert doch noch müssen nur
wenige patienten stationär behandelt
werden ein bisschen die ruhe vor dem
sturm wir erwarten dass die
krankenhauspatienten zu nehmen schnell
zunehmen aber ich mache mir mehr sorgen
um das personal als um die patienten
wenn wir dort
zunehmende ausfallraten haben dann kann
die versorgung im krankenhaus schon an
die grenzen kommen auch deutschlands
zweitgrößtes klinikum dass der ludwig
maximilians universität in münchen
bekommt in den letzten tagen
personalprobleme wie mikron wir hatten
noch nie so viele ausfälle also wir
haben jetzt in den letzten zwei wochen
haben sich die zahlen verdreifacht bei
ausfällen bei personal um auch mit wenig
personal möglichst viele patienten
versorgen zu können hat man hier ein
mittel gefunden das so schlicht wie
effizient ist provisorische wende im
flur unterteilen zwei normal stationen
wir haben normalstation so umgebaut dass
es möglich ist flexibel in einem
kurvenbereich zu verwandeln wir können
das hin und herschieben je nachdem wie
viel kommen können wir bereiche umwidmen
in ein cockpit bereich oder in ein nicht
korrekt bereich viele strategien mit
einem ziel immer alle patienten
versorgen zu können die regensburger
hubschrauberstaffel zum beispiel fliegt
mit festen teams damit im schlimmsten
fall nur wenige kräfte ausfallen auch
wenn omikron wirklich zuschlagen sollte
ich bin guter dinge dass wir das
hinbekommen bisschen vorbereitet und
haben plant unserer patienten hinkommen
und mal sehen vielleicht bleibt die
große welle im krankenhaus auch aus ob
die omikron welle die kliniken trifft
oder nur vorbei schwappt das werden wir
in zwei bis drei wochen wissen
für den 20 januar
1942 hatte gestapo chef reinhard
heydrich in die villa am großen wannsee
eingeladen zu einer besprechung mit
anschließendem frühstück was besprochen
wurde hat ein protokoll festgehalten
dass nach dem krieg in den akten depots
des auswärtigen amtes gefunden wurde
protokolliert hatte adolf eichmann dem
in den 60er jahren in jerusalem der
prozess gemacht wurde bei dem der
ss-mann weitere historische details
beisteuerte bis hin zum cognac den mann
am kamin zu sich nahm als
prozessbeobachterin prägt der hannah
arendt dafür den begriff von der
banalität des bösen
der spielfilm die wannseekonferenz den
das zdf morgen abend ausstrahlt lenkt
darauf das hauptaugenmerk dass auf
dieser veranstaltung der
zivilisationsbruch daherkam wie eine
x-beliebige vorstands konferenz 15
männer gefallen und karriere süchtig um
zuständigkeiten rangeln nach oben
buckeln zur seite treten und die ihre
unfassbare barbara mit bürokratendeutsch
momenten dazu gleich noch ein gespräch
zunächst zeigt claudia armbruster
auszüge des films
es ist eine besprechung mit frühstück
wie in einer firma wie heute die
teilnehmer diskutieren wie sie eine
aufgabe effizient schnell und
kostengünstig bearbeiten können es geht
um 11 millionen und morde
die judenfrage nur es gelöst betrachtet
werden nach der vollständigen
biologischen ausmerzung des gesamten
judentums bis zum ural das ist die
zielvorgabe die aufgabe die das
schicksal uns gestellt hat das war mal
gegenwart das war mal ein heute und das
vor augen zu führen hat mich dann auch
bewogen diesen film zu drehen
diese leute die da sitzen das sind sehr
intelligente menschen gewesen
intelligente menschen die nach
intelligenten methoden suchen
tötungsmethoden meine sorge gilt allein
unseren männern und der seelischen
belastung die die endlösung für sie
darstellt das töten soll
menschenfreundlich ablaufen
menschenfreundlich für die täter
jegliche nähe und mitleid erregenden
reize fallen weg dass wir hier durch
einen angenehmen technischen effizienten
und vollkommen anonym vorgang erreichen
der von unseren männern auf eine sehr
distanzierte art und weise durchgeführt
werden kann das für mich erschreckende
an dieser anderthalbstündigen
unterredung war die
selbstverständlichkeit des vorgangs man
musste ein problem lösen und man wusste
nicht wie und es ging natürlich auch um
macht es ist wie beim
kameradschaftsabend
am ende geht es immer darum den hut
aufhat nur ohne bier
der film zeigt nicht die gräueltaten
nicht die morde rechnung er bleibt bei
der konferenz 100 minuten völkermord
planungen beamten deutsch der vorgang
selbst korrekt durchgeführt ist nach
zehn bis 15 minuten erledigt
anschließend erfolgt die belüftung der
räume sowie abtransport und entsorgung
vom zugleich ins gas es ist also keine
unterbringung erforderlich das ist sehr
effizient dieser film wird
wahrscheinlich auch aufregen und das
solle auch und ich finde es richtig dass
man über diesen film redet sonst hätten
wir einen fehler gemacht sonst hätte ich
einen fehler gemacht
dieser film ist ein eiskaltes
meisterwerk eben weil er ausschließlich
die grausame banalität dieser konferenz
zeigt
wenn es das wirklich die blutbäder der
erschießungen erspart und unsere männer
dadurch geschont werden
dann ist mir das eine große
erleichterung zu wissen dass wir alles
getan haben was menschenmöglich ist
eine besprechung mit frühstück wie in
einer firma wie heute
es war
die wannseekonferenz darüber wollen wir
mit einem der bekanntesten und
gewichtigsten deutschen politik
wissenschaftler sprechen mit herfried
münkler von der berliner
humboldt-universität guten abend herr
professor winkler
und slomka diese yacht bürokratie der
barbarei das was hannah arendt die
banalität des bösen nannte ist es das
was die dieses protokoll zur
wannseekonferenz für die nachwelt
festgehalten hatten in ihrer
einschätzung und einordnung
ja dieses protokoll von dem ja nur ein
exemplar
auf uns gekommen ist und im archiv des
auswärtigen amtes überlebt hat ist
ein
form in der die organisation des
völkermordes besprochen wird in der die
verschiedenen
institutionen und stellen des deutschen
reiches miteinander koordiniert werden
und in dem gewissermaßen in einer brutal
distanzierten sachlichkeit über
menschliche schicksale gesprochen wird
das muss man immer im hinterkopf halten
behalten auch im hinblick auf diesen
film
unterhalten sich hier leute sozusagen
als würden sie einen komplexen prozess
organisieren aber was das ergebnis
dessen es ist ein
gigantischer völkermord wobei man
dazusagen muss dass der nicht erst mit
dieser konferenz begann den den gab es
ja schon längst also wenn man an die
massenerschießungen von 33.000 juden und
jüdinnen bei babi jar bei kiew zum
beispiel denkt dass der holocaust als
solcher hat er durchaus schon begonnen
ihre logos beginnt im prinzip mit dem
überfall auf polen da sind also dann die
ersten messen erschießungen und setzt
sich dann intensiver befragt nach dem
angriff dem überfall auf die sowjetunion
aber
das wird ja auch in diesem film
angesprochen das ist sozusagen noch
nicht industrialisiert noch nicht in
großem stile organisiert und man denkt
darüber nach wie man das ganze
effektiveren kann und dabei tut sich
dann vor allen dingen eichmann hervor
als der dann auch später in der
geschichte bekanntgeworden
organisator
des völkermordes dieser film und
überhaupt dass die wannseekonferenz als
solche mit mit den mit den historischen
dokumenten auf den ausführungen von
eichmann die konzentriert sich ja auf
die täter und und zeigt quasi in die in
die abgründe dieser dieser barbarei aber
das sollte ja auch nicht den blick
verstellen auf die gesellschaft die
dahinter stand auf die mittäter die
ausführten und und auch gerne aus
führten
ja gut die bleibt im film selber außen
vor die wird dann teilweise in der
dokumentation thematisiert das ist auch
denke ich wichtig
diejenigen die man im film vor augen hat
sind die eigentlichen organisatoren ein
paar bedenkenträger darunter aber die
bedenken gelten hier eigentlich nicht
dem völkermord und seinen folgen sondern
eher welche spuren das möglicherweise an
der psychischen verfassung der
erschießungskommandos und ähnlichem er
hinterlässt also man möchte fast sagen
das ist in seiner brutalität kaum
steigerbar nicht und hannah arendts
äußerung in einem prozess in jerusalem
sei sie der banalität des bösen begegnet
ist natürlich auch immer eine heikle
formulierung das ist auch damals so
diskutiert worden weil auf der einen
seite die banalität hervortritt aber auf
der anderen seite man gewissermaßen die
spur des mordes des elends und der
brutalität immer mitdenken muss also es
wurde damals auch darüber diskutiert
dass banalität vielleicht auch ihrem
amerikanischen hannah arendt lebt er in
den usa zu verstehen sei es etwas
allgemeingültiges
aber was man ja auf jeden fall protokoll
dieser wannseekonferenz und auch bei der
verfilmung merkt das böse das
unmenschliche das barbarische das kommt
nicht polternd in ich sag mal
springerstiefeln und mit ordinären
tonfall daher sondern das sind
promovierte juristen beamten die da am
tisch sitzen da werden häppchen gereicht
da wird der cognac am kamin eingenommen
da ist der scheitel gerade gezogen und
die krawatte sitzt
richtig nicht also sozusagen aus dem
blick bleiben die sadisten und die
brutalen figuren die mit der
unmittelbaren gewalt befasst sind ja man
überlegte im kontext der
wannseekonferenz geradezu wie man
möglichst das effektive möglichst wenig
seelische folgen bei den unmittelbaren
täter hinterlässt und wenn man das mit
einem gewissen abstand dann noch einmal
sich durch den kopf gehen lässt dann
wird vielleicht gerade in einem film der
nur die täter und nicht die opfer in den
blick fest das ungeheuerliche dieses
vorgangs noch sehr viel deutlicher
sichtbar aber dafür muss man darüber
nochmal nachdenken und das wird nicht im
ersten anschauen
einem so deutlich
sagt professor winkler ich danke ihm
sehr für das gespräch
vielen dank
das interview haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt den film die wannseekonferenz
können sie hier morgen abend um 20.15
sehen mit einer anschließenden
ausführlichen dokumentation oder beides
schon jetzt in der mediathek abrufen und
jetzt macht erstmal heinz wolf weiter
mit den nachrichten wenige tage vor den
ersten beratungen im bundestag über eine
krone impfpflicht nehmen die pläne der
befürworter konturen an der
stellvertretende
spd-fraktionsvorsitzende dirk wiese der
zusammen mit anderen abgeordneten der
ampelkoalition eckpunkte eine
impfpflicht ab 18 jahren vorbereitet
nannte gegenüber der nachrichtenagentur
dpa einzelheiten
demnach sollte die pflicht auf ein bis
zwei jahre befristet sein und für nicht
mehr als drei impfungen gelten
aus protest gegen die korona auflagen
sind in brüssel zehntausende menschen
auf die straße gegangen nach schätzungen
der polizei versammelten sich etwa
50.000 demonstranten in der brüsseler
innenstadt einige von ihnen warfen
gegenstände auf polizisten und
beschädigten gebäude die polizei setzte
tränengas und wasserwerfer ein
mindestens 70 personen wurden
festgenommen
in oslo haben mehrtägige gespräche
zwischen den militant islamistischen
taliban und westlichen vertretern
begonnen hintergrund des treffens ist
die menschenrechtslage sowie die
humanitäre krise in afghanistan die
taliban sollten auch vertreter der
afghanischen opposition journalisten und
menschenrechtler treffen das ist das
erste mal seit der machtergreifung dass
die taliban mit einer delegation in ein
westliches land reisen
nach dem angriff der terror miliz es auf
ein gefängnis im nordosten syriens
dauern die gefechte weiter an inzwischen
wurden mehr als 130 menschen getötet und
auch zivilisten diaz kämpfer hatten am
donnerstag den angriff begonnen um
inhaftierte anhänger zu befreien von
kurden angeführte truppen versuchen mit
unterstützung der us luftwaffe das
gefängnis wieder vollständig unter ihre
kontrolle zu bringen
der ukraine konflikt die spannungen mit
russland ziehen weitere kreise
nicht nur im baltikum schaut man mit
sorge auf den truppenaufmarsch der russe
auch in schweden wird darauf reagiert
zumindest auf seiten des schwedischen
militärs dass seine präsenz auf der
größten schwedischen ostseeinseln
gotland sichtbar verstärkt man wolle
russland seine verteidigungsbereitschaft
demonstrieren erklärte der schwedische
verteidigungsminister
schweden ist wie das benachbarte
finnland nicht mitglied der nato einer
hebestreit berichtet
stürmisch ist es in diesen tagen auf
gotland dessen pittoreske hauptstadt
wyss be schon oft als kulisse diente die
bi langstrumpf und deutsche krimis
wurden hier verfilmt jetzt ist laut
kulisse für ein ganz anderes schauspiel
seit tagen inszeniert sich schwedens
militär als bereit jeden angreifer von
der insel fernzuhalten
wir haben natürlich eine menge
militärische aktivitäten erinnerung
deshalb ist die situation ganz klar
gespannt gotland ist sich heute aber
recht ruhig situation ist
so ruhig wie eigentlich immer in den
letzten 200 jahren in denen schweden in
frieden lebt aus ihrem standpunkt haben
schwedens verteidiger schon lange keine
angreifer mehr beobachtet trotzdem
rüsten sie auf schicken großzügig
eigenes bildmaterial in die welt wie sie
weitere soldaten und ausrüstung nach
deutschland bringen die insel könnte
nach meinung von militärstrategen
bedroht seien sollte russland neben der
ukraine auch das baltikum ins visier
nehmen
wenn man irgendetwas gegen die
baltischen staaten unternehmen möchte
gerät gotland in den fokus denn in der
stärkung für diese nato staaten käme
dann über die ostsee vielleicht darüber
schwedisches gebiet wenn man die insel
gotland kontrolliert wie kann man diese
verstärkung verhindern
es ist das szenario eines dann nicht
mehr kalten krieges dass sie mit ihrem
schaulaufen hier verhindern sollen es
sei ein ritual das immer dann aufgeführt
werde wenn russland für schlagzeilen
sorgen unterstellen dagegen kritiker wie
der journalist und buchautor matthias
gehören soll die schwedisch military and
will italien das bekommt das schwedische
militär und der rüstungs komplex wollen
immer zeigen dass sie noch gebraucht
werden der einzige grund für schweden
das militär und die rüstungsindustrie zu
brauchen ist der nachweis einer
bedrohung und woher sollen die kommen
wir nicht von russland
damit bezieht er sich auf den begriff
krieg was nicht mehr als 100 jahren die
schwedische angst vor russland oder
russen meint und womit immer wieder auch
politisch gespielt wird auf gotland
allerdings verfängt nicht bei allen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
russen kommen und sich gott land holen
ich weiß nicht wie er macht das angst
das macht mir keine angst das kennen wir
schon ich mache mir keine so
vielleicht ist es ja ein schauspiel wie
das der wellen nach jedem sturm schlagen
die auch wieder friedlich und gut lanz
und
dann schauen wir noch den süden europas
nach italien das den kontinent seit
geraumer zeit überrascht und positiven
wirtschaftsdaten einen viel gelobten
pandemie management und stabilen
politischen verhältnissen dass der
aktuelle ministerpräsident draghi damit
viel zu tun hat erkennen selbst seine
konkurrenten an insofern blickt nicht
nur italien jetzt gespannt auf die
präsidentschaftswahlen die morgen
beginnen wird draghi seinen hut in den
ring werfen um das amt zu wechseln und
nachfolger von präsident sergio
materieller zu werden und was kann das
für die politische stabilität italiens
bedeuten andreas postel berichtet as rom
der quirinalspalast in rom sitz der
päpste bis zum ende des kirchenstaates
und seit 1946 residenz des
staatspräsidenten der republik italiens
eine parallele gibt es dieser tage wie
bei einem konklave ist auch bei dieser
präsidentschaftswahl zu beginn noch
vieles ungewiss jeder in rom weiß dass
die früh genannten oftmals nicht die
gewählten sind deshalb hält sich auch
der heimliche favorit mario draghi
auffällig zurück er will nicht verbrannt
werden zu viel steht auf dem spiel
der wahrscheinlichste kandidat ist
ministerpräsident mario draghi weil er
eine regierung der nationalen einheit
vor steht und daher die mehrheit hat die
die regierung unterstützt er hatte
zahlen um zum präsidenten der republik
gewählt zu werden
doch ein anderer preschte dieser tage
vor der 85 jährige silvio berlusconi
wollte wohl in erster linie seinen
machtanspruch im mitte rechts lager
dokumentieren fraglich ob er die nötigen
stimmen zusammen hätte sein rückzug nun
verbunden mit der forderung mario draghi
solle ministerpräsident bleiben sonst
platze die regierung
was folgt ist ein drahtseilakt der
parteilose sergio materieller war sieben
jahre garant der stabilität in einem
land das die politischen turbulenzen bis
zur selbstbeschädigung treiben kann
ich denke die voraussetzung dafür dass
draghi staatsoberhaupt wird ist das dem
parlament bewusst wird dass italien
einer person braucht die für sieben
jahre seinen westlichen verbündeten aber
auch den finanzmärkten stabilität
vermittelt denn in wirklichkeit hat die
derzeitige regierung trage ihre aufgabe
erfüllt diejenigen die sagen draghi
solle regierungschef bleiben tun dies
also nur weil sie ihn nicht als
präsidenten der republik haben wollen
die frage ob draghi präsident wird hängt
nun maßgeblich davon ab wer ihm als
regierungschef oder chefin folgen könnte
in einem jahr sind parlamentswahlen und
da will sich jede partei profilieren der
parteilose draghi zog wohl zu viel glanz
auf sich
[Applaus]
wenn draghi präsident wird müsste die
regierung umgebildet werden damit die
parteien mehr platz haben weil sie den
zukünftigen wahlkampf gemeinsam
bewältigen müssen doch sollte trage in
einem klima der zerrissenheit jetzt
nicht zum zuge kommen würde die
regierung meiner meinung nach stürzen
und an diesem punkt würde ein sehr
gefährlicher moment beginnen den italien
und damit auch europa noch nicht erlebt
hat
die aufbauten für diesen italienischen
wahlkrimi sind vollem gang corona
bedingt wird es einen wahlgang pro tag
geben für die derzeit positiv getesteten
parlamentarier wird sogar ein drive-in
errichtet jede stimme der
1900 geladenen
sieben jahre in den ferien als palast in
rom einzieht
und jetzt nochmal heinz mit weiteren
meldungen der schauspieler hartmut
becker ist tot er starb bereits gestern
im alter von 83 jahren nach schwerer
krankheit in berlin wie sie eine agentur
mitteilte becker spielte in zahlreichen
filmen mit unter anderem stand der für
die zdf-serie soko münchen oder das
traumschiff vor der kamera auf der
theaterbühne war becker zu sehen etwa am
residenztheater münchen
zum sport und zunächst zur handball
europameisterschaft da ist nach dem
spiel heute gegen schweden für das
deutsche team die chance auf das
halbfinale weg denn am ende war es eine
weitere niederlage wie es dazu kam
martin schneider mit den spielbericht
mitte der zweiten hälfte kommt die junge
deutsche mannschaft gegen den rekord
europameister aus schweden zum ausgleich
die hoffnung auf das erreichen des
halbfinals ist da auch weil trotz aller
corona wirren mit zwölf positiv helm die
moral stimmt lukas stürzte mit dem
anschlusstreffer zum 18 zu 19 letztlich
scheitern die deutschen aber an einer
vielzahl von sogenannten technischen
fehlern das größte minus im neu
formierten team von bundestrainer
gelassen
am ende gewinnen die schweden mit 25 zu
21 nicht immer so kunstvoll wie hier
spielen am dienstag gegen norwegen ums
halbfinale dass deutschland durch die
dritte niederlage nacheinander verpasst
hat
in der fußball bundesliga hat
spitzenreiter bayern münchen bei hertha
bsc berlin deutlich mit 4 zu 1 gewonnen
und seinen sechs punkte vorsprung in der
tabelle verteidigt zuvor hatte er bleibt
sich den vfl wolfsburg mit 2 zu 0
besiegt und damit die krise der
niedersachsen verschärft wolfsburg ist
nun seit elf pflichtspielen sieglos
karl geiger und markus eisenbichler
haben sich beim heim- weltcup der
skispringer in titisee-neustadt den
starker olympia form gezeigt geiger der
schon das skispringen gestern gewann
landete auch heute mit sprüngen auf 131
und 143 meter auf platz eins
eisenbichler belegte wie am vortag den
dritten platz
tennis olympiasieger alexander zverev
ist bei den australian open in melbourne
frühzeitig ausgeschieden der 24 jährige
hamburger verlor im achtelfinale gegen
den kanadier den schapowalow deutlich
mit 3 6 6 7 und 3 6 12 galt beim ersten
grand-slam-turnier des jahres als mit
favorit auf den titel
und zu guter letzt unser blick auf die
nächste woche zwei ereignisse haben wir
ja in unserer sendung schon thematisiert
die präsidentschaftswahl in italien und
die nächste mpk zur corona lage damit
beginnt laura bank ihren ausblick
[Musik]
montag wird erneut in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wie schon
vor gut zwei wochen über das weitere
vorgehen in der korona krise beraten
aufgrund der steigenden zahlen sind
unter anderem neuregelungen bei pcr
tests geplant ob es weitere lockerungen
oder im gegenteil verschärfungen geben
wird entscheidet sich morgen
am mittwoch wird im deutschen bundestag
über die einführung einer impfpflicht
gegen das rotavirus debattiert
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
will eine schnelle umsetzung sollte sich
das parlament für die impfpflicht
entscheiden könnte diese bereits ab
april oder mai gelten
wie hier im vergangenen jahr wird der
bundestag am donnerstag an die
verbrechen des holocaust erinnern in der
gedenkstunde wird die kz überlebende
inge auerbacher für die opfer des
nationalsozialismus sprechen zudem wird
israels parlamentspräsident mehdi eine
rede halten
2021 trafen sich die grünen zu ihrem
parteitag nur digital ab freitag wird
das wieder so sein dann sollen neben
einem neuen bundesvorstand auch die kuh
vorsitzenden gewählt werden ricarda lang
und omid nouripour gelten als
aussichtsreichste kandidaten
und noch der blick aufs wetter zum start
in die neue woche morgen im westen und
süden ein paar größere auflockerungen
sonst meist stark bewölkt oder
neblig-trüb vor allem im osten auch
etwas sprühregen höchstwerte zwischen 3
und 9 card die weiteren aussichten bis
mittwoch ruhiges wetter mit etwas sonne
aber auch vielen wolken nebel und etwas
springen ab donnerstag stürmisch und
deutlich wechselhafter bei 1 bis 7 grad
das war es von uns mit inspector barnaby
geht's gleich weiter und um 0.30 gibt es
dann die nächste heute express und uns
morgen wieder dann aber erst um 22 uhr
45 ist dahin noch wiedersehen für da
sind
[Musik]